[Música]
no hay campanadas en esta escuela para
marcar el comienzo de las clases en su
lugar son esta canción una de las
favoritas de sant boi para ti la música
resuena de forma particular en esta
escuela secundaria pues fue aquí en el
liceo edouard herriot donde para ti
completó la preparatoria universitaria
hace 30 años
[Música]
al pensar en esto hay muchas emociones
encontradas un hombre fue asesinado sólo
por hablar
nuestra libertad de expresión está en
juego
al igual que samuel para ti mattioli
coherencia historia el jueves dedicó la
mañana a discutir sobre su memoria con
sus alumnos
lo veo como un héroe republicano a
través de sus acciones respeto a los
valores de la república francesa
y
secularismo y libertad de expresión para
demostrar su punto enseñar las
caricaturas del profeta mahoma que sea
muy para ti mostró a sus alumnos
tenemos que mostrar los y explicarlos
tenemos que adoptar un enfoque crítico y
racional
en este caso en la primera jornada de un
homenaje nacional de dos días se
realizaron conmemoraciones en la escuela
al rector de la gran mezquita de parís
se unieron unos 20 imanes mientras
depositaba en una ofrenda floral en
homenaje a patti un acto simbólico con
un claro mensaje solidario de respeto y
tolerancia